Drake hosted SNL for the second time and
performed a couple tracks off his new
album views and we might be biased over
here we're pretty sure he killed that's
right he's so huge in the world of
hip-hop that people forget really how
talented he is as enough Danny was drop
in Toronto references and Canadian
references all over the plates that
started from moment one it's great to be
back on SNL where tomorrow at a serrano
in the house snack so as you can tell
I'm from Canada and I know what you're
thinking but no you cannot move in with
me of Trump wins well he was great
throughout the entire episode we did
pull our staff for the top three Drake
moments yes and at number three Drake
singing and looking like a sexy lounge
lizard in sexy kind of evening we got
his walls and the cookies
very sexy now we know I shaved the beard
for that sexist - all right now at
number two it's Drake's beats where
Drake responds poorly to small conflicts
with the style hey anybody using this
chair actually I was it was for my head
but you took it from me now we never
going back
I could never trust you cuz you were
rude to my head if Josh GAD was here he
would have made me laugh and at number
one black jeopardy of course with
references to the TTC rat Moran is
younger Yeager and a certain Canadian
hip-hop star oh snap his new album just
dropped and it's fire Jarrett I got this
who is Kardinal Offishall
excuse me nominated for a Juno Award G
yeah you know it's like you're landed
here on Earth from a spaceship no good
rap comes from Canada
okay what about Drake dawg who are these
people
okay so now we pulled you guys on
Twitter asking do you think that Drake
delivered the last ok 62% of you said he
was the best 14% said he should stick to
music and 24% - said